they're sexy boots but they don't want
mary j blige i have a special guest with
us now as you guys know reporting from
her truck hey rachel how are you
i'm chad i'm good dude i'm the queen of
sexual anarchy are you the queen of
sexual antarctic did you
are you kidding kind of [ __ ] red what
kind of question is that you know i'm a
true blue red-blooded american good good
good did you did you check out the
halftime show or
did you just couldn't handle all the
sexual anarchy dude
oh no i feel so i i feel so um i'm never
gonna recover
i'm you know you can ban all the books
you want now and now i know all about
sex
right well you know you've already read
these books apparently but your your
great buddy charlie kirk kind of blew up
um on the internet uh on twitter by by
saying and i don't really understand
this i can't figure this out i don't
know what part some people are saying
it's because there was shoulder shown
some people are saying that 50 cent was
in the tank top um is the reason why is
the reason why charlie kirk just
couldn't handle all the sexual anarchy
that was happening
can you can you figure out what what the
sexual anarchy was that he's seen
because i can't figure it out
yeah you know i want to remind everybody
charlie kirk's 28 years old
the [ __ ] grew up on victoria's
secret catalogues and that angel
commercial i mean so you tell me tony
what could it be about those individual
skin that they were showing that might
have sparked charlie's outrage i i don't
think it was the butt cheeks dude right
well you know you know it it does seem
it does seem a little far-fetched that
to me that uh charlie i'm a nazi kirk
you know as i call him um would would be
so so so offended by the this super bowl
halftime show which is hilarious he's
like he's like a 90 year old man like a
like a 20 year old's body right
yeah i gotta tell you i'm really lucky
i'm like so old i remember when janice
uh uh when uh what's her name's um
yeah yeah jackson's boob popped out and
the scandal i mean charlie [ __ ] he
wouldn't he'd have to get therapy if
that happened if he saw titty
maybe maybe maybe maybe the titty
affected him in a certain way and he
just he suppressed some of those
memories with the therapy that he got i
don't i don't know i don't know if
there's like conversion type therapy or
what oh no but man if i had time and my
name was gabe sanchez
a water boy shout out about movies with
that i'm just saying
it is it is absolutely insane that that
this is this is where their messaging is
that they think that like the thing
that's going to speak to millennials and
even like jin's ears is that hey we
can't have rappers singing 25 year old
songs and they act like these are like
new songs and like new artists like
these these people are in their 60s that
were singing at the halftime show
like what are you talking like
let's talk about that by the way like
what the [ __ ] are they drinking up there
down there in hollywood tony
because like i want to look like that
when i'm 60 for sure
you know i was talking about this
because snoop dogg and and here's the
thing
of course they're really [ __ ] their
butt hurt that he was smoking as if they
just found out that snoop dogg smokes
weed which is really [ __ ] weird
really [ __ ] weird that they're like
oh he was smoking weed like he's [ __ ]
wind doesn't he he's snoop dogg
he's constantly smoking it takes a
lifetime pot smoker to pull off threads
like that purple [ __ ] suit he was
rocking right that sweatsuit
nope
show up no one else could show up and do
a hammer
in a sweat suit
i had to go out and like rap macklemore
right after that you know because those
threads are slick dude come on dog
speaking of that like stoop dog you were
saying something must be in the gin and
juice because snoop dogg like he looks
the exact me and my wife are talking
about
he looks exactly like you can tell dre
is aged right uh mary j blige she she's
aged 50 cent as age same with eminem but
snoop dogg looks the exact same as he
did 30 years ago like he i don't know
what it is and tony you'd be proud to
know like you know when you give it
every man like us like you know access
to a good rolodex i start using that
[ __ ] someone remember i talked to
someone from hollywood i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing up there man
what is it give me some of that [ __ ] i
want it i want to look 20 years younger
than i do right now
that's right what's in the gin and juice
snoop dogg what's it must be the chronic
that he's smoking it has to be
that's what they're so upset about as he
smokes the weed he looks that young so
so let's go because i know i know
everyone wants to know strategic outrage
and everyone thinks that this is kind of
like a joke how we clown them but this
really is part of their messaging like
charlie kirk just got off a really bad
week where he lost a big fundraising um
for his nazi academy excuse me his uh
his his america first academy where he's
trying to indoctrinate children like
they're really trying really hard to get
a lot of rich people involved
into doing the thing that they accuse
the left of doing right of
indoctrinating kids and um and this is
part of their so is this like do you
think that this is his way
of messaging to young people i mean i
can't figure this [ __ ] out because ben
shapiro's on this train this morning too
about this
that's because like the crt myth you
know that they're gonna wedge in the
fall like a component part of that is
porn okay so like yes there's race
they're going after all these black
authors
but they're what they're hiding their
racial racial motivated [ __ ] behind is
this idea of sexual innuendo right so
like they feel like if they what they're
trying to do is set up this entire frame
that like you know democrats want to
poison your children and turn them into
hedonistic you know drug using party um
you know sexual deviants right and so
like that there's like there's nothing
that comes out of kirk's timeline
shapiro's timeline that chick sarah
iscar on uh george stephanopoulos show
that i watched yesterday when they get
on t when chris christie gets on tv the
dude has a [ __ ] mission dude and
that's a messaging mission right not to
go and have a conversation it's about to
get [ __ ] done right so when charlie kirk
sent that tweet out i immediately
recognized
and part of this component attack on
education to come privatize and make
nazi academies and if somebody doesn't
make that point to these suburban
parents oh you know this is what they
mean they want to make nazi academies
for kids right turn their little kitchen
breakfast marks and you know have a
police state like we're we're gonna be
in trouble so you know because they
really are so good at at making a
messaging garden grow
well yeah well i mean they've done this
for years with with the sex and the
video games you know it's always the
same old [ __ ] that they recycle right
and it's always it's always to get back
to this
us and them right whatever that means
and it's it's it's to make sure that
there's a superior person and and how
that superior person is going to react
to certain parts of culture right and
and and i think it's interesting that
you make you make the point that they
they're trying to make the the older
the older artists black people
performing at the super bowl some kind
of sexual thing which honestly when i
watched it like especially the most
sexual parts which mary j blige had on
like the night the high boots and she
was beautiful she was beautiful did a
fantastic job but you compare that to
tucker carlson talking about how they
took the sexy boots off the m m like
those two things don't [ __ ] match
like what are you talking about you
can't have one and not the other and
then you think well what are what else
is the sexual the sexual anarchy and you
go to the 50 cent part of it because
that when he's singing his song there's
a lot of women dancing around him that
has short shorts on they have like tank
tops on
show in history right but if you but if
you actually go back and you look at the
the official music video for that song
those women are way more scandily
dressed
during that halftime show and i don't i
don't think that it was intentional or
unintentional or pepsi are the producers
of the hash time shows part to make it
sexual or non-sexual you know i don't i
don't think that really played into what
they were trying to do with the show
right like that that wasn't the overall
theme the theme was hey there's a lot of
[ __ ] millennials between the age of
28 and 40 that are gonna [ __ ] love
this music oh [ __ ] and they're gonna be
dancing in their living rooms and their
children are gonna be looking at him go
why are you dancing like that like like
that was the goal it had nothing to do
with sex or anything it was it was to
sell pepsi to millennials that's what it
was about that's what it was about
dude i mean i would hope enemies killing
it on the dl's today on apple i'm sure
that that album's gone viral because i
think a lot of these youngins have never
heard that and that's right you know
that's right yeah
well
people need to understand tony about
entertainment let me just make this
clear because when i found this fact out
i was like and nothing shocks me but
this shocked me i was watching one of
those histories of the 80s shows on cnn
and it was talking about mtv and our you
know i kind of remember when mtv first
became available at least to us but like
that was a little bit late like they
they started the germination seed in the
70s and michael jackson could not get on
mtv when they when he first wanted to be
put on mtv the executives were wary
about including a black artist right in
1980s on mtv michael jackson guys and
like of course they ended up doing it
right did you get thriller and bad and
all these great um mj videos out of the
deal but they had they were hesitant
because they thought white america will
bulk if we have a black artist on this
and now it's 20 20 it's 40 years guys
like you know so it's not that i'm still
alive
right this is in my lifetime where they
were ahead of serious conversation so
here's the thing with kirk if that had
been you know what's her name carrie
underwood and she had boobies bouncing
and she should have a kid popping out
and he'd be fine
right well yeah absolutely
he's just he's just trying to utilize
look at the scary black folks and their
sexual generations you know well i mean
i mean you you go all the way back you
you said
michael jackson who's known as the king
of pop you go back to what they know as
the king of rock and roll who was elvis
elvis
elvis was gyrating and they hesitated to
put him on tv because of it but it was
much better for him to sing black music
because elvis sang black music
and put him on tv as a white person
singing black music than the black
people singing the black music because
they couldn't do that either right
way back then so like this is part of
this whole [ __ ] that they're trying to
stoke this fascist [ __ ] this right-wing
[ __ ] um and i i agree with you and i
think it's not to be ignored you know a
lot of people like oh you're amplifying
their voice you're giving them credence
by talking about them like you have to
clown them you have to show america that
this is what they want
yeah yeah and guys if we don't talk
about their crazy no one else is going
to do it for us well yeah well i mean it
is insane to me how many racist white
people and i'm not uh because i don't
think what charlie kirk said was overtly
racist he definitely has the racial
undertones like you're saying but there
were people on twitter like just being
outright just straight racist they
didn't not care i don't know how many
accounts were probably banned yesterday
uh after the halftime show but there was
probably a lot of counsel suspended for
saying the [ __ ] that they were saying
but but the the crazy part to me
about this
is that
they're okay with black guys
playing on the field and cheering for
the black guys on the field playing the
football game and that kind of
entertainment but they're not okay with
black people singing during the halftime
show they're not okay with that kind of
entertainment and i i'm just wondering
what people yeah listen tony if you've
hit something really important there
okay because it's that is that
intervening variable of team right so
like they're okay
they'd be fine if we brought out some
black artists that like you know we're
republican i'm sure there's like one of
them on the d-list somewhere
like that like you know i mean like
obama right like they're the like the
backlash to obama is racial but it's
conditioned on not being on team right
so this in group out group hostility and
that's why you can have successful
people like herman cain or whatever
right so like when we talk about racism
like we're not talking necessarily and
not often talking about the kind of
virulent uh racism that that was the
stasis of the nation through the 60s
okay what we're now talking about i
would call is more unconscious or
implicit
types of racism that condition how we
see [ __ ] and we would have seen all
white people do the same dance you
wouldn't heard [ __ ] from charlie kirk
about it
right well and and i've made this point
before that i think people need to
understand about fascism because we've
talked about it me and you on this show
and and we've talked about it privately
even that when fascism comes you won't
have the nfl the way you see it there
won't be the nba there won't be
entertainment the way that you know it
like they fascism will not only try to
get rid of black artists but try to get
rid of all memory and you being able to
listen to them at all like that music
that you heard and you love and you love
to dance too the fascist will try to
make sure that you do not have access to
any of that and we see it in the book
banning we see it in the book banning we
see it in charlie kirk at [ __ ] trying to
have nazi schools to where they erase
all semblance
of of black culture because that's what
they do is well that's what they did in
i mean in germany what really made the
[ __ ] notable that they did with the nazi
party as it rose into prominence
especially driven by goebbels who was a
once in a lifetime and he's an evil
genius but he was a love once in a
lifetime like elon musk kind of level
innovator and what his innovation was
was psychological
manipulation through propaganda at a
grand scale right and so like you know
in terms of of um like germany's aims
they did not just aim to set like a
fascist regime into government they
thought the culture of germany was
headed down the the pooper because it
was the roaring 20s people are drinking
women are starting to have sex outside
of wedlock and start to ask for
more political freedom in fact they
enfranchised women right before the rise
of the nazis okay so like you know
the the wiping of culture when they took
the museums they whipped out all of the
impressionist art from these museums put
in only nazi approved artwork really
people i urge you to go read the beast
garden of the beast by um
oh god what's his name eric larson he
wrote also wrote splendid in the vial on
churchill great
way to understand when this these
changes start to come and some of them
already are coming we're watching them
come right now you're gonna understand
like why we're in a crisis and the
biggest crisis of all is getting people
to see the crisis
well and i i think even this trucker
convoy shut down the economy type [ __ ] i
think this plays into that message as
well even though it does like how in the
hell can can sexual anarchy play into
that shutting down the economy like well
what do you think anarchy is like
they're for anarchy they're just not for
the sexual type they want anarchy we
want to shut this down we want to shut
which is really funny because they've
been bitching about supply chains and
opening up the economy now now the goal
is to shut it all down hell yeah they
they want to win [ __ ] right so how do
they win [ __ ] they keep inflation and
they can complain and be uh you know
call biden by inflation right i mean we
know is that i know exactly everything
they're going to do in the fall exactly
how they're going to do it and we have
to meet this moment with fire
so what fire do we give let's talk about
the fire because i think that's
important to not just add the
conversation about what their message is
but how do we not not just combat it
because we need to combat it but we also
need to have something of our own to
make sure that that our quote-unquote
propaganda that's always a bad word but
our propaganda our message is
filled with truth but also getting a a
message out there that applies to all
these situations because for him to call
uh something that happens sexual anarchy
he's blanketing this message right
because he he can say that and it
blankets anything because we're like
what the [ __ ] does that mean so we need
to make sure that we're doing this where
we have this national blanket message
that can be applied to any issue and
make sure that it's in a way that is
pro-democracy and anti-fascist so how do
we do that how do we combat them but
also have our own message of pushing it
out there and getting that strategic
outrage as we talk about
yeah i mean the real thing is
replication right so like they have this
decisive infrastructure advantage in
their right-wing media ecosystem which
is much more than box it extends into
local press local newspaper local tv
i think she lost signal
that is but how do you replicate or get
around or deal and work with what you
have right and what we do have is a lot
of media that is currently
not centralized not focused on attacking
the republican party or highlighting the
republican party's crazy wants to spend
their time having substantive debates
about interesting and
really critical policy and what i'm
telling people is we all need to
practice strategic outrage and
understand that if you have a platform
of any type you're also influencing
others and you can use that platform to
shape language get people to stop
calling it a trucker rally and call it
something else because it's not truckers
right it's it's an insurrection it's an
insurrection right we're trying to
overthrow the government sabotage right
so stop i mean anytime
and and the media loves this like
convenient [ __ ] so like jan six instead
of the republican party's ongoing and
you know multi-faceted coup plot right
right uh trucker instead of you know um
anti-vaxx you know white supreme i mean
these are nazis at these things right
so like they you know you serve them up
something like trucker rally and then
everyone will tweet it everyone will
talk about it we're not we're not
helping ourselves in that right because
because we're we're using their message
to try to form our message which is
exactly the opposite of what we need to
do um because speaking of nazis in this
this trucker this trucker thing in
canada the the crazy part to me is
gofundme is like nope you cut off
we know what you're doing and and it's
not fun it's not funded by people in
canada it's like 90 of truckers
in canada actually vaccinate that's why
they don't have to actually have a
mandate which they're bitching about
something that doesn't exist and the
reason why that doesn't exist because
they don't need it like when over 90 of
people are vaccinated you don't need a
mandate that's not a thing that you need
because it's a it's a done deal at that
point i mean you're talking about less
than 10 who gives a [ __ ] like go go do
what you want to do you know you don't
have to drive a truck and go do
something else
protesting the policy that's right right
i mean that's just that's just the
[ __ ] excuse right right that's the
sexual anarchy that's the sexual anarchy
component of it right
that's the little message the little
nugget that they need to cause chaos to
try to have an insurrection and overturn
democracy because that's really what
they're attacking at this point is
they're not attacking the economy
they're not attacking supply chains
they're not attacking the mandate
they're not they're really attacking
democracy and it's these these these
other actors out there that definitely
do not like democracy that don't want it
here don't want it there they don't want
it anywhere because democracy breeds
anti-fascism right like it breeds it
like that's that's what it inherently is
is anti-fascist when you have democracy
so
but they're trying to overthrow these
governments but more than anything
they're trying to spread this message
that democracy bad democracy doesn't
give you good things democracy give you
bad things like is the message that
they're trying to send so how do we how
do we as pro-democracy people to fight
back on putin's message because that's
where all this trickles down from that
[ __ ] guy
i mean jesus christ we have the entire
[ __ ] republican party
being putin's puppies here in america
act acting as if oh well putin wins that
that's a biden loss so that's good for
geo
horrible for america
horrible for america
they don't give a [ __ ] at this point
because fascist state better
better
that that is what our goal is no matter
what even if we have to support a
foreign actor who would definitely
definitely be our enemy in any other
circumstance we have to be his friend
because it it gives us the power to
overturn biden's tyrannical whatever the
hell they're talking about whatever
exactly yep exactly i mean that's pretty
much it tony and you know at the end of
the day like we don't have we don't have
a big ass media system that we can set
uh on one wheel and have it hum but we
can replicate it as best as we can
by teaching people the importance of
language specificity in language when
you're bitching about congress what you
mean republicans in congress better say
republicans dude right average person
doesn't understand why gun control isn't
passing why climate change isn't passing
they think it's you they think it's us
right we have to tell them you don't
have the [ __ ] you want because the
republican party is blocking it and they
intend to do worse to you i think you
tweeted out
several days ago and i'm gonna get this
completely wrong but you said basically
the energy needs to be turned around of
democrats didn't get anything done that
it's republicans fault that democrats
didn't get anything done and we need to
turn that message in and aim that
message that direction very quickly for
the 2022 midterms um you know i i say so
many times to people that you know joe
manchin and kirsten cinema are not
running for senate they're not running
there's not a race in their race this
this cycle so to to con continue to
[ __ ] about them it's not going to do
any good we can go win ohio we can win
florida we can win those seats and
that's that's what the message is
against um cinema mansion if you want to
have it let's go win those seats that we
don't have and increase our majority in
the senate
because
democrats are the only ones that are
going to deliver voting rights at this
point we watch every single republican
vote against them because they want to
destroy our right to vote they want to
destroy women's liberty i mean they want
to destroy everything for that matter
because sending those cuckoo cause like
you know for i mean look at mark kelly
right i mean he's in the same state he's
a democrat too right being democrat
doing just fine right right
if she had no electoral incentive to do
what she was doing and nobody has any
idea what the hell she her calculus is
but when it comes to mansion dude people
think oh mansion doesn't want to do it
because he's got coal money and i mean
i'm sure all that [ __ ] matters dude but
at the end of the day you take joe
manchin and put him in a biden 35 state
he's voting yes on climate change [ __ ]
that's right
he'd have done busted the filibuster is
what you're saying
[Music]
who are listening to my voice right now
and that's because of the republican
[ __ ] party the republican party
divested itself from governing the
nation about a decade ago figured out
they could still win elections
regardless because of better marketing
and um you know how they campaign and
they've never looked back right so like
when they come into a congress in 22
when they came in in in um you know in
the past their objective is to
is to use their power to thwart your
agenda in every possible way that they
can if that means stealing a supreme
court seat fine that means canceling
democracy fine that's who you're up
against you're not fighting democrats
you're not fighting corporations
lobbyists you're fighting the republican
party and it is time that we all put our
full trained you know verbal arsenal
towards that goal right well because i i
think if we don't we if we don't have
the strategic outrage to make sure that
democrats can deliver to
prevent republicans from destroying our
democracy um we won't save it so it's
very important that we aim it in that
direction and i think we have a lot of
good things working for us um i i think
i think there's a lot of good things
happening out there but we have to stay
focused we can't just say oh well
everything's gonna fall into place we
have to continue to push we have to stay
pissed we have to go [ __ ] vote and
and i don't just mean mark a ballot i
mean we have to get engaged um in these
races and do that thing
yeah and i argue that we should help
people get to that moment and feel that
way by full-on napalm of the gop i mean
we should prosecute the republican party
on climate change first off it's their
like oil and gas [ __ ] that killed the
environment then when they found out
they were killing it they decided to
invent climate change as a hoax right
not with all lobbyist money and it was
the same people that did uh doubt about
smoking and cancer okay that's who
brought you climate change as a hoax
that's not organic either that was a
strategy that they financed deployed and
did and it ended up turning like there
was never like not a partisan divide in
environmental data now it's like this
okay that's what they did and they
because of that and their continued
obstruction even as the emergency has
become much more obvious uh you know
these this future generation gen z jet
millennials they need to understand we
didn't get here by accident and we're
not getting out of it unless we roll
over the republicans
right well because that's the only
option that we have because they're not
they're not they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop vote for that
[ __ ] never dude so you older have to get
them out of the way or
you know just don't expect [ __ ] you
can't do [ __ ] with this government
unless you have enough votes in the
right places to do it and you know like
i said joe manchin is the last democrat
that will ever serve in the state of
west virginia okay because he has to get
30 people almost 30 of the republican
vote to survive in there right so
no one can get that [ __ ] like 10 is the
cap so manchin getting that extra 20
is a function of mansion himself and
once he's gone that will completely turn
red and it will not elect a democrat at
least without another historic
realignment um intervening into american
politics which cyclically could happen
in 50 years but in the in the meantime
that west virginia you can't primary joe
manchin he doesn't he's afraid of
republican voters not you
right right well that's why he's doing
what he's doing yeah because he has to
get the vote right no [ __ ] he's a
senator
he's 30 it's a 35 plus trump state
right
it is west virginia
he was 65 35 or 70 30 or something like
that dude you know you know before we go
but i want to ask you one more thing
about january 6 and some of that but
speaking of the the west virginia
doesn't it doesn't it floor you that the
messaging that that democrats could have
to attract what would be known as
conservative voters on issues like
people in west virginia they want decent
[ __ ] wages like they don't want to go
bankrupt because of a [ __ ] health
care bill like they want they want
decent jobs right like they want their
families to have a decent way of life
they don't want to be [ __ ] broke like
the exact that's the exact opposite of
the republican message
somebody's got to come in there and say
look republicans have been controlling
your ship for 20 years where's all your
[ __ ] right exactly
oh wait a minute you have less than you
had 20 years ago
what a surprise let me tell you what
they did to steal all your [ __ ] okay
like that's the kind of messaging you
need you can go into west virginia all
[ __ ] day and say oh look this
provision of bull buildback better pulls
at 60
well then re-poll that west virginia
audience and then pop in democrats want
to do this republicans want to do that
and you watch that support plummet dude
right right that they want that but
unless you understand the power the
intoxicating power of hyper partisanship
you are never going to be able to get
that through to that audience
and that brings me that
hyper partisanship brings me to some of
the news that is coming out of the
january 6 with some of this um seditious
conspiracy we've seen the oath keepers
um they were having [ __ ] conference
calls apparently
um to plan to plan this thing yes and
and and everyone's wants the january six
select committee to arrest people like
right now which is not how it works um
but but in and i've been saying for
several weeks and even months that hey
the january 6th select committee is
going to tell a story here and if
democrats and you out there democratic
voters do it correctly we can actually
use that as a message of what they're
going to do with our country if they
take back power right like all the
things they wanted to do that they were
not successful at they are going to try
to do again and i i think it's important
for people to remember because i did an
interview
with tasha adams which is the exchange
ex-wife of stuart rhodes the founder of
the oath keepers i also his son joined
us
and
their their view of it was is that the
oath keepers
kind of did a 180 for donald trump right
like their entire organization was in
the exact opposite direction of what
they actually did with this seditious
conspiracy and a lot of it was to
protect stewart rhodes himself um it has
a lot to do with the bundy ranch and i'm
hoping i can have him back on but the
point that i'm trying to make here is
that these people were willing to go
against their entire their entire life's
work of beliefs to maintain power for
this this idea that one authoritarian
could give them what they want like this
is fascism 101 this is the sexual
anarchy [ __ ] all rolled into one and we
can actually use the story that january
6th select committee is gonna tell over
the spring and summer as it a little by
little by little like we can let the
american people know who don't know now
i have a friend of mine the other day
rachel i was talking to him about the
the white house destroying documents and
like what are you talking about what are
you talking about i have no idea what
you're talking about
i keep yelling at twitter i'm like dude
normal people who even vote have no
[ __ ] idea any of these headlines and
we won't find a way to tell them what
has happened and force them to see it
right that distribution and isn't
something you can just you know
we'll just dial it in [ __ ] it you know
no we gotta get him to look we gotta get
him the information get him to look okay
and this is no small task so i'm gonna
close out by saying this you're
absolutely right getting liz cheney to
run that committee adam kissinger
they're running that [ __ ] like a
republican committee except for it's a
republican committee for the first time
with an actual scandal to investigate
because keep in mind usually they're
just making [ __ ] up right so like in
this case the meat is just as rich as
the politics and liz cheney is counting
on somebody to be there to hit the ball
that she's gonna serve up once these
committee hearings start our system is
not geared to hit the ball and that's
why you see me every day on twitter
yelling hey we've got to get this [ __ ]
fixed and we got to do it by april 1st
right well and i i think we got good
opportunity and we can do this thanks
for reporting from your truck today what
kind of favorite place on earth dude
it was i i really i i wanted rachel on
mondays it's kind of a thing we've been
doing so i appreciate you joining us
even from your truck and we'll have you
back next week to talk about whatever
these [ __ ] psycho
fascists do over the next weekend
because they always seem to serve us up
the the ease of messaging over the
weekend um
we certainly don't lack for material to
work
with absolutely absolutely not rachel
thanks for stopping by we'll see we'll
see you next week um hopefully we'll be
able to bring in maybe next monday as
well if you're not too busy thanks
rachel
everyone stay here we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds
467 000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels